monsieur bonsoir une semaine après les
attentats la mairie commémore ses
disparus et intensifie ses contacts
diplomatiques pour préparer la riposte
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu exige ce
soir des talibans la remise immédiate et
inconditionnelle du suspect numéro un
oussama ben laden le premier chef d'état
étranger à rencontrer george bush depuis
la tragédie et jacques chirac
il est arrivé ce soir à washington en
entretien prévu de longue date qui a
pris une toute autre ampleur après la
série d'actions terroristes françoise
roy
c'est à 23 heures heure de paris que le
président jacques chirac est arrivée à
la maison blanche pour des entretiens
suivi d'un dîner de travail avec george
walker bush
dès son arrivée le président français a
confirmé la solidarité de la france
j'ai voulu dire au président bush et qui
est mon ami et au delà de lui au peuple
américain
d'abord la solidarité totale de la part
de la france et des français
la solidarité du coeur j'ai voulu dire
aussi et leur dire notre détermination
qui est sans réserve pour lutter avec
toute l'efficacité nécessaire contre ce
nouveau type de mal absolu
j'évoquais à l'instant de président et
que le terrorisme et romaine région j'ai
confiance sur le fait que nous avons
travaillé ensemble sur le même objectif
vous aimez la liberté elle devait nous
rejoindre c'est le sens de cette réclame
à l'objectif et puis demain
jacques chirac se rendra à new york sur
les lieux de la catastrophe